the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show our
president obama late last week created
the largest ecologically protected area
on the planet when he expanded a
national marine monument in hawaii to
encompass more than half a million
square miles the president more than
quadrupled the size i I'm gonna have
trouble with this i believe it's
pronounced the Papa had now moku a kya
is that at all in the ballpark valiant
effort I would I give you points for I
110 points the papa Hannah Leah kya
marine national monument to over five
hundred eighty two thousand square miles
of land and sea in the northwestern
Hawaiian Islands interestingly president
george w bush not exactly known as the
environmental savior of the planet
established the monument a decade ago
President Obama now growing it even more
uh can anyone really have a problem this
I mean I I know that always there are
people who who will say government just
shouldn't get involved in this but it's
not like I don't believe a hotbed that
that of companies wanted to develop for
natural resources I don't think it was a
target for that was it so statistically
what I think will happen here is so in
mobiles first term you a bit you know he
deported three million immigrants Trump
claims he's gonna get rid of 11 million
yeah so I think that Trump is gonna go
and expand this four times you make it
that a two was it two million square
mile Matt National moment it would be uh
500 yeah basically try because Trump's
gonna win again he's gonna do everything
absolutely better I one thing I do like
about this is that it includes ocean and
oftentimes when we look at the very
active protection of areas its land and
sometimes you'll see like for example
the Riverkeeper type organizations which
look at rivers what's happening in the
oceans is an absolute train wreck
disaster we know about garbage island
that the sort of small plastic Island uh
that that exists in
Pacific based on the currents that are
out there yeah you know I I can't ever
help but feel like it is sort of always
too little too late but we we should
applaud this I don't I don't know what
else to say yeah this is a great thing
there are vital ecosystems that are very
unique to this island in the Pacific and
they're gonna be well protected I know
they're they're very much untouched
there are some places like around the
Big Island have been vastly destroyed
due to you know modern industrial
civilization but for the most part a
pristine and they will hopefully remain
that way let's talk about a very very
bizarre reversal involving Isis Isis is
reportedly band women from wearing
burkas in northern Iraq and you might
say wait wait a second aren't they
enforcing the wearing of the burka what
appears to have happened is that some of
their fighters were targeted by a veiled
female and uh they are they are now
saying no more burka because we need to
be able to better protect our terrorists
from a woman who showed up and actually
killed two of our jihadists so now if
you go into the security centers near
the mosel stronghold you can't wear the
burka anymore this is a group with so
many internalized contradictions that it
it is absolutely beyond words at this
point their critics of the left but yet
they are trafficking in profits from
fossil fuel oil gasoline they are the
ones who want to enforce the burka and
the West is not strictly and and solidly
Islamic enough yet now they are at risk
at of of having their jihadists killed
by a woman wearing a burqa so now it's
no more burka in northern Iraq to me
this is not it not doesn't really
require a specific analysis it's about
the sort of absurdity and total lack of
any consistency period in anything that
the Islamic state is doing and and as if
we needed more information or
confirmation of that this is it sweater
they're gonna be waiting at the yet the
gate to the mosque with bikinis Hannah
bikinis or what's what are they gonna do
it's so funny because uh first you see
the groups that
and the traditional uh attire from many
religions which makes it very difficult
to identify who many people are and
makes it much more difficult to hide
items on you and we often say hey if you
had to go through TSA checkpoints
wearing just underwear it would be far
more difficult to hide anything and then
all of a sudden now because of security
concerns the Islamic state which is the
group perpetrating many of these acts
says we really gotta strip down the
women at least to begin with only by
removing the burkas because we just want
to make sure that they're not carrying
weapons yeah that's exactly what we're
saying and when and you're the problem
in many cases but now you're having the
same problem we're having and you've
come to the exact same conclusion what
this does confirm to me is that the idea
of going through security wearing
underwear which I don't support actually
but as a thought experiment i think is
interesting might actually be really
effective because saying no burkas is
just one baby step in the direction of
less area that could be hidden I'm glad
to see terrorism has finally hit the
terrorists yes is perfectly do justice
here hey uh I want to talk about what's
happening in Colorado with the prices of
marijuana the cost of a wholesale pound
of marijuana in October in Colorado was
around twenty-five hundred dollars per
pound that has been almost cut in half
to around fifteen hundred dollars per
pound last month according to data from
an online marijuana distribution
platform which is as you can imagine
studying this very very seriously that
it is called i believe it's pronounced
creative although it might be tragic
saying in nearly a year we've seen
wholesale prices drop to nearly half of
their previous totals we've never seen
prices like this and this is because the
market is flooded right growers are
ramping up production there's a huge
amount hitting the market in Colorado
and this is causing the deported decline
in prices regardless of demand and as we
know Jason demand is very very strong in
Colorado right now for legal weed
similar story from Washington state
where the price of legal marijuana has
also dropped since significantly to the
senseless first dispensaries opened
so there this is sort of a double-edged
sword right on the one hand you are now
allowing people to do this legally and
that's a great thing you can tax it
revenues to Colorado have been huge you
can take that money and use it for drug
addiction education really thinking of
drug addiction as a health issue not a
criminal issue it's all absolutely
fantastic at the same time we are seeing
the price go down very very
significantly which we could argue is
bad for the growers but it is also good
in terms of eliminating the black market
because we've reported over the last
year that the black market for for pot
in Colorado still exists because due to
regulation the recreational legal
marijuana cost was still higher so you
get the black market and they say hey
were not regulated we're not paying
taxes so we're going to be able to offer
a lower price this is good news in terms
of making the black market dealers
basically unnecessary or moot or
obsolete because the prices are dropping
what very drastically on the legal side
and I things can be great thing also in
that whenever I say whenever because I
feel like it will happen yeah the de
actually gives a green light research to
happen it's gonna cause the the cost of
the research a very cheap and next thing
you know they're gonna be creating all
of these compounds CDB compounds and
they're gonna destroy the pharmaceutical
industry CBD CBD Commons yeah I agree
with you I mean right now there are so
many obstacles to research not that big
pharmaceutical companies can't go out
and score some pot they would be able to
but big picture yes if it's cheaper that
is also going to facilitate research
although the schedule one disaster of
mayor of cannabis is one of the problems
the difficult way in which research is
even possible is one of those problems
so there's a lot of different issues
here uh on balance I understand that
this will impact growers profit margins
are still very solid for growing
marijuana I think big picture this is
actually going to be a positive thing
and that you have to remember that even
if the prices go down at the wholesale
level when we have more legalization and
more markets the opening of new markets
is going
to do way more to help these businesses
remain profitable and many of them are
very very profitable I've been reading
about it I'm not finding myself hugely
concerned with the decrease it really
does make sense one you once you bring
something legal there is going to be you
know I'm not a total free market guy but
there is going to be a market force that
is going to decrease the price that's
just expected yeah and especially as so
I know that's going on in Northern
California similar to there is companies
like marlboro have been going to buy all
these huge tracts of land scenarios
which are optimal for for creating this
right but what I hope is this can get so
low in price that it's gonna keep the
curse certain kind of a small growers in
business and not allow for these huge
big business wholesales like marble etc
to come in and take over the market I
think they are going to come in and take
over the market if really we see
legalization we've already seen a
variety of different patents start to be
filed including even by the government
in terms of medicinal uses I think that
big pharma and the tobacco companies
both are laying the groundwork so that
if legalization as in terms of
recreational use becomes widespread they
are absolutely going to be there and
honestly I don't know that there's much
we can do to prevent it from happening
no there's nothing we can really do to
stop it I know they have been setting
the muscle cells up they have been
buying the land in these certain areas
like the law as I know in California if
you buy a 10 plus a cure attractive land
you can basically do whatever you want
their right and it's hard to find these
properties and I know something from my
friends that are kind of initiative Sri
if you will sure I like that a nice way
to say so so what they're doing though
is in California they've given kind of a
a chance for these people to catch up in
this year last year and next year you
had to try to legalize themselves so
when the when the ballot measures do
come up they actually do have the money
to apply for these ridiculous kind of
permit fees and that's same thing of
Massachusetts I think the the cost right
now is you have to pay three rounds of
fees to become a medical marijuana
dispensary in Massachusetts right now
and it's 80 50 and three thousand
dollars
our sorter actually and I thought it was
more to be honest I spoke to a lawyer
who who worked with some clients who
were soliciting I believe he told me
that the entire process if if and up to
including the ex the acceptance of it is
half a million and I don't know if he
was including the expected legal fees in
that as well but I've heard that these
are just absurd numbers well just legal
just me not excluding legal fees the
actual three fees you have to pay the
permit fees are those but yeah I i have
heard as well that you need to have
basically half a million upwards of
really a million dollars to start this
and the interesting part is it has to be
a non-profit business right so you have
to find a way to somehow circumvent all
of the the nonprofit kind of uh
restrictions are there not to mention
most banks won't do business with you
because federally this is still
something that is illegal and in
addition to that you also have uh a
situation where you're handling major
major cash payments and you sometimes
need heavy security and you have a
non-profit which is hiring security in
this way not that nonprofits don't they
very often hire security no doubt about
that it's just a nightmare it's an
absolute and total nightmare I saw an
interesting advice interesting piece on
vice of us actually and there's actually
a security they have a certain security
company that basically is the backbone
the kind of the pulse of this industry
and they go from every dispensary and
they have this huge ball it's like its
own it's like a private bank essentially
of all these ex-military people that are
running its kind of kind of very
interesting to see that is interesting
yeah and look at look at the industry
that's being created because so many of
these businesses have to deal with cash
okay that's the bonus show that's it for
today and we've got such a great week of
shows even though it is a short week
because of late
it is quality over quantity discreet the
david pakman show at david pakman.com